hi I'm Eric Minich with IBM cloud I want
to tell you a little bit about
continuous integration today this is a
development practice that just about
everybody thinks they're doing but it's
widely misunderstood so I want to start
by talking about you know the bad old
days before we had it what problem we're
trying to solve and what this does for
us and what's really about so let's
start with our old-school approach where
we've got a couple of developers they're
probably on a team of 30 or 50
we got Alice and Bob and they're working
on their own features and they're gonna
keep separate on their own features for
a long time right so you know they're
they're writing some bits of new code
here you know maybe they're they're
deleting a line of code here they're
what have you in their plan is that
they're gonna get their features to work
against the code base and then a couple
of weeks or months later they're going
to integrate their work together they're
gonna merge their work together they're
gonna say my code your codes got to come
together it's all going to work now in
this world you could have a situation
where Alice and Bob well they changed
the same line of code here right and
maybe Alice changed this code but then
Bob deleted it and so this gets really
awkward really fast when you just try to
algorithmically combine it right you get
what's known as a merge conflict this
gets worse because it might be that some
code up here interferes with some code
down here they they just don't work
together and you've got bugs and this
will happen here within just one file
but in the real world it's not just two
developers working on the same file
there's thousands of files or millions
in an application there's tens of
developers involved and they're doing
this over weeks and weeks and so
reconciling all of these problems big
mass called merge hell
so it's like well what do we do to avoid
merge hell this is how we got here well
we start and we'll have Alice writing
some code again right
Alice writes her code cool as soon as
she has something that works even a
little bit her feature is not done but
she's got code that works it doesn't
break things she submits that in the
source control Bob pulls down the same
code before he starts working right he
always is working off the latest Alice
is always submitting hers in Bob makes
his change right maybe he deletes a line
of code great Alice comes back she's
working another part of her feature
she's working on another feature she
grabs Bob's code cool and now they're
working on these things together in the
likelihood that they're both working on
the same thing at the same time and that
they conflict it's pretty small and if
they do hit that it's all on code
they've worked on in the last day right
they can sit together and they can
reconcile this thing that's no big deal
and so the core principle that we're
seeing here one of my favorite things in
software developments it's so
counterintuitive is that if it hurts do
it often and it won't hurt so much and
that helps us get rid of the big big
bogey here right which is you know we're
gonna not have merge hell we don't like
merge he'll get rid of that okay so
that's that's fixed number one now this
does create a new problem though right
they have a whole bunch of people
constantly checking in code into the
codebase things are gonna break right
it's not going to compile there's gonna
be bugs that weren't there yesterday and
you have this kind of continuous
integration led to continuously broken
problem and that that's sad so what do
we do well we put some automation in
right and it's always watching the code
keeping an eye on it
and whenever a change happens it says
okay let me grab that code I'm gonna
build it and then I'm gonna test it all
right I'm gonna run my unit tests so if
there's any change build it test it if
anything in here fails then we email the
team right we let Alice Bob the whole
team know say hey there were two new
changes since last time I did a build it
looks like both Alice and Bob touched
this thing it's broken now they need to
go fix the codebase good so now we've
got a safety net that enables continuous
integration good the other thing that
we're getting though is that we always
have this build all right
so whenever the test team wants to go
test it in more depth right to run a
heavier level of test than the unit
testing that we're doing here they've
got to build they know compiles and it's
the newest stuff right so that's our
other key benefit coming out of
continuous integration is that we always
have a testable build so there you go
continuous integration was addressing
the old way of infrequent integration
saying if it hurts we're gonna do it
continuously we're gonna do it a lot
that avoids merge Hal keeps our
developers productive and it gives us a
constantly testable build so that's
continuous integration in a nutshell
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line and if you want to see
more videos like this in the future be
sure to LIKE and subscribe